[Musik]
hey ihr lieben ich mache heute mit euch
zusammen eine hübsche eisbombe und bei
der eisbombe ist natürlich auch dass wir
verwenden essentiell
daher nutze ich mein heutiges video um
euch das gute eis in demeter qualität
vorzustellen und das heißt wirklich das
gute eis und das gibt es exklusiv in den
sorten vanille und schoko in allen
kaufland filialen und bei mir ist es
wirklich so wenn ich mir das gute eis
kaufe dann können wir uns das richtig
dann ist es wirklich das bewusste
genießen
dann setze ich mich auf die couch oder
auf dem balkon und schlimm dass so
richtig und ich zeige euch wirklich wir
eben ganz klein und fein und kurzen
schritten eine hübsche eisbombe
zubereiten können und damit könnt ihr
eure gäste zum beispiel überraschen oder
auch zum geburtstag meine alternative
zur geburtstagstorte und hier sind jetzt
noch so die restlichen zutaten die wir
benötigen neben das gute essen demeter
qualität hier habe ich nämlich himbeeren
ich habe hier frische verwendet ihr
könntet auch wunderbar tiefgekühlte
nehmen außerdem vollkorn butterkekse
haferflocken hier habe ich noch butter
und außerdem für den schokokuss auch
noch mal butter und vollmilch kuvertüre
das heißt dass ich jetzt ein paar
minuten anschauen ich zeige euch jetzt
in der zwischenzeit aber den boden und
dafür nehmen wir uns ganz einfach einen
mixer oder fette kinder habt könnt ihr
das auch mit dem nudelholz in einem
gefrierbeutel machen einfach rein geben
und grob malen und anschließend die
geschmolzene butter dazugeben
[Musik]
die mischung für den boden den wir jetzt
ganz groß an die seite und wenn das eis
streichfähig ist können wir anfangen
unsere schüssel vorzubereiten ich habe
hier eine schüssel die ist hier oben im
durchmesser 18 zentimeter groß da könnt
ihr euch gerne daran orientieren und da
gebe ich jetzt frischhaltefolie rein
können wir das später ganz einfach lösen
und dann beginnt ich persönlich mit
vanilleeis sie können das auch umgekehrt
machen je nachdem was ihr euch für eine
optik wünscht
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt hier eine wand
hochgezogen der darf auch ruhig ein
bisschen dicker sein und in die mulde
gebe ich jetzt unsere himbeeren wie
gesagt also ich finde außerhalb der
saison passen da auch tiefkühlware
wunderbar jetzt haben wir noch frische
daher nehme ich die diesmal und wenn ihr
die eingegeben habt auch gerne schon
einen rand rücken kommt das
schokoladeneis dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im anschluss einfach nur noch die
oberseite schön bat verstreichen das
funktioniert am besten mit einer winkel
palette und jetzt fehlt ja eigentlich
nur noch unser boden aber ich gebe das
jetzt eine halbe stunde ins gefrierfach
damit dass so ein bisschen fest werden
kann eine oberfläche und da müsst ihr
den boden auch nachher wunderschönen
anrücken können also sehen wir uns
gleich wieder so die erste halbe stunde
ist rum und jetzt können wir ganz
einfach den boden darauf geben und ihr
könnt euch gleich auch noch ein glas zu
hilfe nehmen und das ganze schön fest
andrücken
[Musik]
so ihr lieben jetzt müsst ihr ganz stark
sein denn jetzt kommt die eisbombe für
mindestens sechs stunden in die kühlung
also ins gefrierfach ihr könnt das ganze
auch am vortag vorbereiten oder was ich
auch super gerne mag ich habe das so im
gefrierfach manchmal auch über ein bis
zwei wochen hinweg und falls ich besuch
ankündigt habe ich immer eine leckere
eisbombe da aber wir sehen uns in sechs
stunden wieder so ihr lieben die sechs
stunden wartezeit sind rum aber bevor
ich die reformierte im gefrierfach hole
zeige ich euch wie eine ganz schnelle
schokoladenglasur dafür geht wir haben
jetzt hier die zutaten für mich
kuvertüre und butter und ich mache das
ganz einfach so ich gebe jetzt die
mutter direkt zur vollmilch kuvertüre
und dann kommt das ganze bei mir auf
niedrigster wattzahl in die mikrowelle
für zirka eine bis eineinhalb minuten
und dann ist die klasse auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
der guss ist fertig und ich habe jetzt
mal eine eisbombe aus dem gefrierfach
genommen einem tollen tag ist auch schon
bereit und dadurch dass wir das jetzt in
frischhaltefolie umwickelt haben geht es
auch super easy raus aus der schüssel
und dann stürzt ihr das ganz einfach
[Musik]
ich hoffe natürlich dass euch die idee
zum rezept gefällt und dass ihr das
ganze gerne mal nach macht wie gesagt
bei diesem rezept ist geschmacklich
natürlich das eis essentiell
also probiert das gute als gerne mal aus
und schreibt mir euer feedback hier in
die kommentare
und falls ihr schöne fotos schießt dann
markiert nicht gerne mit dem hashtag
liches kitchen auf instagram ansonsten
dem video ein dörfchen nach oben da
lassen das abo nicht vergessen die
glocke nicht vergessen denn dann
verpasst ihr auch keines meiner videos
mehr
und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr beim
nächsten mal wieder dabei sein auf die
gis kitchen tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]